chris is in Charlotte welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Chris hey how you doing
Dave better than I deserve man what's up
hey not too much I just wanted to call I
am actually a content creator
I run a live show three nights a week on
twitch TV cool where I play games and
believe it or not people pay me to play
video games I'll bet they do
gaming gaming is a big deal man cool yes
yes sir yeah so my question is do I need
how do I need to handle this channel
we've seen some moderate success the
last few months we're still a baby
channel but for tax purposes whether I
need to be if it's like a contractor or
if the American right if he's a small
business and do you need to get
insurance like as a public figure it's
not me right I play a character but do I
need to get insurance on American right
you know does that make sense Dave so I
know it's super interesting or unique
ooh I love it that's fun well the first
thing you do when you get a business
started is you separate the businesses
finances from your own and so I assume
you're getting ad revenue or sponsorship
interview or something like there are
revenue or something like that right yes
sir yeah so twitch pays me every month
for how many subscribers I have they
give me a revenue share of my
subscribers yeah it kind of like a
YouTube model okay yes sir
all right very good very good and that's
your that's your only revenue stream
right now yes sir and depending on
people can donate to the channel or drop
bits in the channel that's what they
call it on twitch right so some people
are more generous than others and some
ones are more generous so yeah exactly
so you can kind of if you give fun
advice some I'll give you a tip yes
there exactly yeah we like to I like to
think we give world class b-plus
entertainment gameplay love it that's
fun good for you okay then what you do
is you open up a separate checking
account in your company name just give
your little company in name it doesn't
have to be anything except a sole
proprietorship in your social security
number it's called a DBA doing business
as so Chris whatever your last name is
DBA doing business as whatever your
company name is Chris is gaming or
whatever
okay and so you've just got a you go
chris is gaming or whatever your company
name is checking account all of the
income goes into that checking account
from the business it never comes into
your personal account without first
going into the business account and then
any expenses that you have associated
with the business if you're upgrading a
computer you're buying up a controller
or you're doing something that's
exclusive to the business that you can
write off as an expense of an equipment
purchase whatever that might be I don't
know what it might be but you take on
you pay only business expenses out of
Chris's gaming account the business
account and then what's left in that
accounts profit if the business income
comes in and only business expenses come
out by definition then what's left is
called profit and then when you take
that home out of your business account
you write Chris the person a check out
of his business account you set aside
1/4 of that for taxes because if you
make more than six hundred and forty
dollars a quarter you're supposed to
file quarterly estimates on your taxes
and so if you pull a thousand bucks out
of this account you would set aside two
hundred and fifty of it for taxes and
put seven hundred and fifty into your
checking account set 250 over in savings
so you've got the money to pay your
taxes when you do your quarterly
estimates if you pull ten thousand out
of that account
you do 2,500 over in savings for taxes
and seventy five hundred comes home and
so forth
and so that's that's the very starting
point that you do and no I don't think
you need insurance because there's not
really any way you can harm someone with
this advice they the likelihood of you
being sued is almost zero and at this
stage of the game now if you get up to
where you're generating a million
dollars a year in revenue or something
like that you probably do want to
transfer your your business ownership
into an LLC at that point but I want you
know I wouldn't fool with it right now I
would just keep it as a sole
proprietorship just keep everything very
basic primitive basically and easy to do
easy to use and run it that way but if
you really start making some money then
you would do that for instance
when I started first started doing this
I ran it as a sole proprietorship until
we started making it had a top-line
gross revenues of a million dollars and
then I put it into a sub S corp we later
transferred it to an LLC but you put it
into a corporate structure so that if
you get sued they don't get at your
personal stuff and then what you would
do is you would look and see if there's
anything in the gaming world anyone in
the gaming world that is selling
insurance to you guys captain and I
doubt there is I'd I can't I can't
imagine that you would do something that
would actually cost somebody serious
money yes sir okay well that make sense
that make sense well Wow I really
appreciate it it's awesome to talk to
you and hopefully one day the American
riot will will be as successful as a day
of Ramsey show hey I got a feeling it's
gonna be man it's on fire you are too
well done proud of you a good job